you know what's funny is that oh and
also I'm not going to have an alarm on
the house and on my kids windows or yes
you will
um we'll see why you want them to sneak
out
uh look if I'm still doing comedy I'm in
a new material about how they try to
sneak in and we're too drunk and fell
through the window
hilarious that you're thinking that you
missed a lot of Opera you missed a lot
of opportunities with me about possibly
a company coming home and you sitting on
the couch and turning on a light and
going I've been waiting for you yeah but
you know what I that means I'd have to
stay up yeah I know I was staying up
later back then I figured it out you
were I figured out ways to sneak out you
want yeah I figured out where's this
[__] how okay so you did put a sensor
for the alarm on my window in my bedroom
second time I opened it it would go the
bedroom window yeah it's just Gladys was
so annoying we named our system glasses
um but
if my window was open
and you turned the alarm on
and I didn't move my window
my window could stay open
um
and so I just had a screen and I would I
would leave my window all the way open
and then I would let you guys turn off
the alarm I would remember how I lost my
screen eventually yeah yeah I kicked out
my screen too many times I kicked a hole
in it is why were you kicking it out why
aren't you just lifting it and bringing
it inside I was a dumb kid and I thought
it was funnier that way I thought also
at one time I came back kind of high and
I tried to kick it in and I was like oh
that's not how that works so I kicked
the hole through it and that's when I
stopped sticking out because I didn't
have a screen door anymore you didn't
just want to use your hands
yeah no I was like I was like it was
like [__] Tom Cruise I was like I
love that yeah